Let's go next to Rishard from Brooklyn,
Rishard from Brooklyn. You're on the air.
Rashad from Brooklyn, please, on mute,
and you will be able to talk to me.
And yes, oh, you. Am I coming through clear? Yes,
you are. Perfectly clear, pristine. Beautiful.
You know, the second caller
from New York, actually. Yeah.
What can I do for you, Rashad?
So I think Stacey Abrams is I mean, I
guess in reference to the previous caller,
Stacey Abraham has been a hero for the Georgia
Senate election and even the presidency.
And I think she showed that there probably
are more swing states if Democrats are willing
to work. Right, and I was wondering and yeah,
and I was wondering if you thought there were
any other potential swing states that Democrats
would just just enough resources into, that we
would be able to maybe possibly slip them blue?
Well, North Carolina is a state that is sometimes
blue. That could be much more reliably blue with
more Democratic effort. But then Texas is the sort
of obvious big one because the reward is just
so big and we thought it would be closer than
it ultimately ended up being. I never thought
that Democrat that Joe Biden would win Texas,
but there was the idea that it would be close and
it was sort of close, but not as close as maybe
we would have wanted. I think Texas, particularly
with a lot of liberals moving to the Austin area,
I think there's major potential. And
the reward for making Texas at least
sometimes blue would be absolutely devastating
to the Republican Party at the national level.
Yeah, I mean, if you like, can
you imagine if Democrats actually
find a way to make Texas a swing
state, like Republicans would never,
almost never win an election?
I mean, yes, it's it's really not far from being
a swing state, it's close to being a swing state.
And I think the lesson from Stacey Abrams should
be, let's put four years into Texas starting
now, so that it can be a swing state by 2024.
Yeah, that sounds like a great idea. Yeah.
Well, I guess that's about it. Thank you, David.
All right, thank you. Do you know any particularly
good Argentinean restaurants here in New York?
Yes, yes, go to it's called El Gauchito and it is
in the Corona Elmhurst area of Queens. Excellent,
excellent Argentinean restaurant. I don't
know what's going on from the standpoint
of the virus right now and dining there, but
fantastic Argentinean restaurant in Queens.
Thank you, David, I appreciate it.
My pleasure. All right, there is Rishard
from Brooklyn. Very, very exciting.
And you never know what you're going to get.
When you show up at an Argentinean
restaurant, let's go to Chris from Colorado.
Chris from Colorado, you're on the air.
Chris.
I know you are so low, you sound like
you're 100 feet from the phone, Chris.
Wo. Chris, are you there?
Yeah, man, I don't know what
people are doing when it sounds that
like I really I can't and that like,
do I ever sound that way on the phone? I don't
know. Let's go to Adam from D.C., Adam from D.C..
And David, how are you doing?
Good. How are you? Pretty good.
I'm wondering what realistically, now that the
Democrats have a tenuous lead in the Senate can
get done? I don't think D.C. statehood or
Puerto Rican statehood is on the table, but
maybe some smaller stuff.
What would you like to see done?
The stimulus bill, I think that gets done to
climate change controls stuff of that nature.
Yeah, I think that I mean, listen, some of the
climate stuff can be done by executive order
because Joe Biden trumpet damaged a lot of climate
stuff by reducing regulations via executive order.
Joe Biden can put them right back in. Now, that's
small potatoes. We want more. And I'm being very
clear. We want more. We want a big legislative
deal. I think the dream would be a major
infrastructure, green energy, sustainable business
deal, like a big, really big, big deal. But in the
immediate, Joe Biden can can undo some of Trump's
economic damage. Regulatory ease is loosening
of regulatory climate related regulations via
executive order. I think the stimulus gets done.
I think the bigger questions are, you know, do
do we really get a good shot at a public option,
et cetera? I think and it remains to be seen.
Do you really think that the public option is
on the table? I mean, the well, it's Biden.
It's what it's on the table in the sense that
it's what Biden ran on. And until he proves until
he shows me he doesn't actually want to try it,
I believe he will at some point try to do it.
And then whether it can get done is the question.
Yeah, that's kind of what I was alluding to.
I know that we don't have a filibuster proof
majority, so we can just simply kill it.
They can. The question would be at what political
cost? If it's very popular and it is, the question
would be what? At what political cost. And I think
it's great to be thinking ahead about this. But
let's see how the next two weeks ago and
let's see how Biden's first two weeks
of executive orders go. And then let's
start building the legislative agenda.
Sounds good. David, thanks for taking
my call. You have a great day, sir.
My absolute pleasure. Thank you so much.
That is going to do it for calls today.
We will take calls again,
and I hope you will join me
for a whole new week of shows. But we'll be
back with more right after this quick break.